después de días de violencia
interpartidista en irak un
pronunciamiento que puede calmar los
ánimos el líder de quienes se acercaban
armados el parlamento les pidió detener
la violencia así habló moqtada al sádr
sigo creyendo que mis seguidores son
disciplinados y obedientes y si en los
próximos 60 minutos no se retiran así
como del parlamento abandonaré a estos
seguidores a
los manifestantes concentrados 30 el
parlamento iraquí protestan por el
estancamiento político que vive el país
producto de la incapacidad de formar
gobierno desde hace 10 meses cuando se
celebraron elecciones en las que el
movimiento de sádr ganó la mayoría
aunque insuficiente para formar gobierno
a la inestabilidad política se suma la
atención religiosa entre las distintas
facciones chiítas en irak miembros de la
milicia pro iraní hijas xavi contraria
moqtada sádr se enfrentaron con los
seguidores del líder político al igual
que los militares un hecho más en la
escalada de violencia que ya ha dejado
al menos 23 personas muertas en bagdad y
270 heridas luego de que el anuncio de
sádr sobre retirarse de la política
calentará los ánimos sader pide
disculpas y digo ahora que camino con la
cabeza gacha y pido disculpas al pueblo
iraquí que es el que está agobiado por
lo que ha sucedido
en la tarde del lunes los manifestantes
invadieron el palacio de la república
que albergaba al consejo de ministros
pero hoy tras la declaración de sádr sus
seguidores se muestran obedientes a su
llamado contra la violencia